[موسيقى]
الان وبعدما تابعتم وشاهدتم طائره ايه ام
جاء الدوره للحديث عن مراحل تصنيع هذه
الطائره الضخمه وكذلك المده الزمنيه التي
تستغرقها حول هذا الموضوع سنتعرف على كل
هذه المعلومات من السيده رافائيل بوتيو
رئيس الصيانه والتحديث لطائره اي 400 ام
بشركه اولا مصر رافائيل اهلا بك معنا في
عسكري ايتاليا يعني دعنا نتعرف على مراحل
التصنيع وكذلك المده الزمنيه التي تحتاجها
طائره ايفور هاندريد ام حتى تكون جاهزه
للتحليق
ويلكم
الى منشاه تركيب طائره اي 4 ام يشرفنا
وجودكم هنا معنا هذا هو المكان الذي تبنى
فيه طائره اي 400 ام وتختبر وتطير لاول
مره قبل تسليمها الى العميل ومن اجل تحقيق
ذلك فنحن يستلم المكونات من مناطق عديده
من اوروبا الاجنحه مثلا من بريطانيا
والمثبت الراسي من المانيا ومكونات اخرى
من فرنسا وتركيا ودول اوروبيه اخرى فيما
يتعلق بطائرات النقل لا هناك الكثير من
الشركات التي تقدم طائرات نقل ما الذي
يوجد لدى طائره اي 400 تستطيع ان تقول انه
لا يوجد في طائرات النقل الاخرى
هي اكثر طائره متعدده لاستخدامات متوفره
حاليا وهي تستجيب لتشكيله واسعه من
احتياجات القرن الحادي والعشرين للقوات
الجويه العالميه والمنظمات الاخرى
وبامكانها تنفيذ ما لا يقل عن ثلاثه انواع
من الواجبات الهجوميه والمهمات
الاستراتيجيه مباشره الى موقع العمليات
كما بامكانها ان تعمل كخزانه فهي الحل
المثالي لانزال الحمولات من ساعات
المتدنيه وانزال الجنود من الارتفاعات
العاليه والمنخفضه مثلا 40 الف قدمي
للقوات الخاصه وبالاضافه الى ذلك وكما
تعرفون فان طائرات اي فره ام حلقت
بارتفاعات منخفضه خلال ظروف مناخيه محوريه
لانها كما نعرف صممت لتكون منخفضه وصعبه
الكشف عنها
فيما يتعلق ببدايات طائره ان كانت هناك
شكاوى فيما يتعلق بالمحرك وعدم قدره
المحرك على تحمل الوزن الكبير الذي تتحمله
هذه الطائره وكذلك امور اخرى تتعلق
بالهيكل اولا هل هناك اي شكاوي الان فيما
تتعلق بطائره ايفور هاندرد ام
كان
بامك ان تقول بكل سعاده من كل التحديات
التي واجهناها والتي قادتنا الى هذه
المرحله من الزمن تستحق جميع الجهود التي
بذلناها نرى طائره اي 4 بكل فخر وهي تعمل
كقوه من اجل الخير في الحرب ضد كوفيد 19
واجلاء المدنيين الافغان من كابول او
لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه في باكستان
هذه مجرد امثله عن خدمات طائره اي 4
لمجتمعاتنا